шановні глядачі вітаємо вас на каналі DV
українською Мене звати Анна пшомиська я
журналістка української редакції
Deutsche Welle разом зі мною сьогодні
Ганна гобко голова правління мережі
захисту національних інтересів Анс і
голова комітету Верховної Ради із
закордонних справ у 14-19 роках пані
Ганно Дякую що знайшли час і приєдналися
до нас дякую за запрошення я з першого
анонсую про що ми говоримо ми
обговорюємо саміт України ЄС який
відбувся у Києві сьогодні це вже 24 за
ліком саміт але перший у якому Україна
бере участь у статусі кандидата у
членство до Європейського Союзу Отож
сьогодні до Києва прибули 16 посадовців
із єврокомісії фактично усе керівництво
Євросоюзу і це все попри загрозу
ракетних обстрілів попри повітряну
тривогу яка тривала сьогодні на тлі заяв
про можливий масштабний наступ Росії і
на тлі нових поставок зброї із Євросоюзу
зокрема пані Ганно на тлі у цих новин на
вашу думку Як ви скажете що хотіли
європейці продемонструвати тим що
приїхали до Києва саме в цей час і
приїхали фізично наголошу на цьому Ми
дуже правильно зауважили тому що цей
24-й саміт відповідно до протоколу мав
бути в Брюсселі але відбувається в Києві
і це чергове підтвердження що
Європейський Союз має амбіції бути
геополітичним гравцем І саме завдяки
співпраці і в перспективі членстві
України або Європейському Союзі це можна
я вважаю досягти Тому це дуже важливо
зважаючи також і на
онкоін мовілезей нам мобілізацію яка
постійно триває в Російській Федерації
на загрози чергового наступу
Ось і військові експерти говорять про
грізні сценарії але присутність тут це
також розуміння потреб України зокрема
військовій сфері тому дуже добре що це
виходить просто за оцінку виконання
Україною семи критеріїв а Європейський
союз дивиться як то кажуть ширше зокрема
цей візит в такому потужному складі
якраз і є підтвердженням Так Тобто ми
бачили у Києві і урсулофондруляйн
президент у єврокомісії і очільника
європейської дипломатії Жозе па буреля І
голову Європейської ради Шарля Мішеля І
дійсно велика делегація з Євросоюзу
прибула сьогодні у Київ і все ж таки
ключове питання яке стоїть перед усіма
це Ну коли Україна врешті стане
повноправним членом Європейського союзу
а для цього нагадаю потрібно що дуже
багато зробити тобто найперше - це сім
критеріїв сім рекомендацій які
Євросоюз надав Україні ще влітку коли
надавав статус кандидата Тобто це по
суті називається тут це рекомендаціями
Але по суті це умови правильно які Київ
має виконати для того щоб стати членом
ЄС навіть не для того щоб стати членом
ЄС А щоб спочатку ЄС дала дав оцінку
виконанню цих рекомендацій а потім щоб
могли розпочатися переговори про вступ
які теж є довгим тривалим складним
процесом ось з цього приводу хочу
згадати Що прем'єр-міністр Денис шмигаль
сказав що вже за два роки можливо
Україна стане членом ЄС а Володимир
Зеленський так само оптимістично
налаштований з цього приводу і до речі
давайте послухаємо що він сказав у
своєму вечірньому зверненні напередодні
Я вірю що Україна
заслуговує вже цьогоріч підійти до
відкриття переговорів про членство в ЄС
я дякую пані президентці єврокомісії та
її колегам і нашим друзям є за відчутно
підтримку на шляху інтеграції та у
захисті нашої держави і людей пані Ганно
Чи поділяєте ви такий оптимізм що
переговори можуть початися вже цього
року що Україна може стати членом ЄС за
два роки чи бачите ви якісь передумови
для цього чи чи налаштовані оптимістично
ну дивіться головне не втрачати динаміки
і також мати розуміння
внутрішньополітичної ситуації в
Європейському Союзі виборів які там
відбудуться Ось і вони теж можуть внести
якісь свої корективи Тому очевидно я б
розділяла відкриття переговорного
процесу яке важливо зробити в цьому році
І тому ми чекаємо на проміжний звіт який
буде весною Ось і далі уже яка буде
оцінка зокрема того опитувальника який
Україна заповняла і плюс ті речі тому що
ми нашої коаліцією аналітичних
експертних центрів ми оцінили в 5,8
балів виконання Україною і десь дали
такий дедлайн чи Термін до виконання для
того щоб до початку червня Верховна Рада
уряд
президент як національна збірна
зібралась і зрозуміли що наприклад там
конституційний суд потрібно врахувати ті
рекомендації які є з венеційської
комісії ті зауваження застереження які
від експертного середовища в Україні і
фактично як нам порадили представники
від Європейської комісії Україна Має тут
не виконати на 100%, А на 120 щоб
взагалі не було до нас жодних зауважень
і переговорний процес відбувся в цьому
році чому це важливо на ті речі які я
сказала але є ще інша історія - це
щодо членства тобто
термін там два роки хтось каже там три
роки інші називаються я думаю що якщо
буде переговорний процес то Він
відкриває вже нову сторінку для України
Це так само як ми здобули статус
кандидата і це пришвидшило хоча
наприклад візьмемо досвід деяких країн
західних Балкан ось тому ми можемо
сказати що ми прорвалися вперед і там
роками тривають переговори ну тобто це
надовго може тягнутися і тут зважаючи
так само що говорити 24-й рік вибори і в
Сполучених Штатах Америки вибори в
Російській Федерації вибори здається і в
Молдові невідомо як будуть розгортатися
події на полі бою в Україні і так далі
тому мені здається що наше завдання
переговорний процес має бути відкритий
зараз і тому мені дуже хотілося щоб в
уряді і в парламенті дуже серйозно
підійшли до голосу озвученого експертним
середовищем що потрібно доробляти і
продемонстрували не імітацію а
продемонстрували справді налаштованість
виконати перевиконання 120% про які вже
говорять в Європейському Союзі Дивіться
якщо говорити конкретніше
прості сім рекомендації так сім кроків
які має зробити Україна перед тим що як
почнуться переговори тобто ці ці умови
для вступу там і конституційний суд Як
ви вже згадали продовження судової
реформи і де олігархізація і закони про
медіа нацменшини тобто з оцього всього
потрібен потрібно з 10 а то і 12 так з
10 якщо рахувати тими балами про які ви
говорите урсула фондуляєнт вчора на
прес-конференції з Володимиром
Зеленським досить таки позитивно
висловилася про прогрес України до речі
давайте послухаємо що конкретно вона
сказала
ви продовжуєте досягати вражаючого
прогресу у виконанні семи рекомендацій
єврокомісії я тішуся бачити що ваші
антикорупційні органи напоготові і є
ефективними викриті корупційних справ Я
також схвалюю швидку реакцію на
політичному рівні для забезпечення того
щоб боротьба з корупцією приносила
відчутні результати і посилювалася
надалі
тобто протягом останніх двох тижнів Ми
бачили дуже активні викриття звільнення
обшуки підозри Ну прямо такий якийсь вир
новин з цього антикорупційного фронту
Так
чи це все не імітація боротьби з
корупцією Чи чи це початок реальної
реформи реальної боротьби з корупцією Чи
це шоу для демонстрації європейським
партнерам що у нас щось відбувається от
з вашого погляду як це виглядає
ну по-перше це дуже добре що журналісти
громадські активісти після певних спроб
в такий спосіб закритий донести
представникам влади Що крадуть під час
війни і це взагалі Ну є абсолютно не те
що неприйнятно ось це державна зрада
фактично коли не почули то змушені були
йти в публічну площину ми побачили певну
реакцію але чи достатньо цієї реакції
очевидно що ні і перебуваючи в Лондоні
на минулому тижні де ми говорили з
представниками і МЗС і інших відомств
дуже чітка була сказана фраза чи сигнал
прозорість щодо корупції не означає
незворотності покарання коли ми побачимо
невідворотність покарання для тих хто
зловживає службовим становищем хто
продовжує грабувати державу це я вже
продовжу от тоді ми повіримо що ви
дійсно боретеся з корупцією тому що
просто звільнень любих друзів президента
про Факти їхніх зловживань всі знали і
раніше ще до повномасштабного вторгнення
ось просто хтось закривав очі і тому для
нас важливо навіть давайте Для мене це
дуже больно Тому що перед тим як Ми
займалися адвокацією статусу кандидата
тоді Було дуже гостро питання щодо
призначення керівника сап і ми навіть
посилалися на але Призначити керівника
сап до того щоб спростити адвокацію
громадськими експертам Ми їздили в
Стокгольм в Берлін в Париж в гаагу
переконували ключових партнерів дайте
нам не гібридний формат а саме статус
кандидата тоді що тоді не було 100%
гарантії ми це вигризали І це б нам
допомогло Тому зараз коли ми дивимося на
історію із призначенням набу Я дуже хочу
щоб зробили висновки із тих помилок які
були під час призначення керівником
керівника сап і ми продемонстрували що в
ті антикорупційні інфраструктурі яку
після Революції гідності ми створювали і
питання тут я назвала набу дуже важливе
призначення сап є ще питання відновлення
електронних декларацій які були
заборонені чи як скасували електронне
декларування з початком війни і ми вже
побачили величезну кампанію більше 25
тисяч підписів зібрано Я вважаю що
Верховна Рада мала би продемонструвати
не просто як ми прибираємо мандати від
п'ятої колони але повернути
електронний декларування під звітність
суспільству Я розумію що є питання там
е-е
безпеки але я не кажу щоб ці всі
електронні декларації були миттєво в
доступі для всіх Ось але вони мають бути
в доступі до правоохоронних
антикорупційних органів щоб вони могли
перевірити чи не збагачуються під час
війни і тут не треба 3 млн електронних
декларацій там від якогось з ним
представників місцевого самоврядування
яким вже зараз там заборонили ви кордони
жінкам депутатка місцевого
самоврядування і так далі але це мають
бути принаймні всі представники
Верховної Ради уряду всі топ
офіційні особи і тоді хай набу матиме
можливість перевірити електронні
декларації
і це також буде потужним сигналом
повернення електронних декларацій до
того що ми рухаємося не тільки до шоу
але й до реального маючи вищі
антикорупційний суд також до
незворотності покарання і це сигнал в
першу чергу тим хто сьогодні В окопах що
Поки вони воюють з ворогом ми тут
забезпечуємо все що повернення із фронту
буде в країну
міцну де не буде місця тим мажорам Чесно
кажучи ну інколи Ну не буду це
коментувати бо це дуже для мене болісно
тема особливо на фоні загиблих але кажу
підсумовуючи меседж наших партнерів
прозорості щодо корупції без
незворотності покарання це не є
переконливо щодо того що ми дійсно тут
тим хто зловживає хто краде ставимо їх
як то кажуть законодавчі рамки зараз
уряд намагається це все пришвидшувати ну
тобто постійно лунає Давайте швидше
швидше швидше швидше Це нам на користь
грає чи як кажуть наші партнери
Ми бачили вже турборежим
І чого це потім коштувало тому
надмірна швидкість визначає якість тому
я вважаю що особливо з призначенням
керівника набу можна не тиснути на
конкурс підганяючи когось можна там
терміни якраз такі щодо початку березня
Ми все встигаємо не потрібно робити тих
кроків які
в когось складають враження що хочуть
призначити свого Навіщо це зайвий раз
якісь речі коли
Можна почекати кілька тижнів провести
конкурс відповідно до всіх процедур і не
як це кажуть в древньому Римі здається
Спишіть повільно
серед цих семи-семи кроків з вашого
погляду з вашою оцінки де Україна
досягнула найбільшого прогресу
ну дивіться
в яку В який би ти саме критерій не взяв
будуть якісь речі де треба чи після
ухваленого закону Верховної Ради Ми
чекаємо на вступ Як закон про Медіа Плюс
кажуть що додатково треба ще закон про
рекламу ухвалити що стосується нас
меншин чудово там виконали повністю але
потрібно урядом нормативно-правову базу
там ухвалити і так далі хороша там я
зауваження з боку Угорщини з боку
Румунії зауваження з боку Угорщини поки
Орбан при владі і використовує Угорщину
як російське проксі в Європейському
Союзі і НАТО вони будуть завжди і на
одній зустрічі з представниками
Євросоюзу Ну я сказала кажу навіть якщо
вся Україна буде говорити угорською
мовою
ці зауваження нікуди не зникнуть давайте
чесно говорити Угорщина блокувала
комісію Україна НАТО Угорщина не
підтримувала що раніше я це пам'ятаю Що
сів коли працювала очолювала комітет
закордонних справах коли американці
намагалися якось знайти порозуміння і не
змогли тому що в Угорщині була своя
кожен раз коли вони літали в Москву не
з'являлися додатково претензії і так
далі ми за політику добру сусідства але
це політика має бути як рівноправних
партнерів без приниження України без
якоїсь за кулісами російської гри і так
далі дуже високі були очікування в
принципі цього саміту хотілося якоїсь
конкретики чи варто чекати швидкості і
конкретики від Європейського Союзу У
плані української євроінтеграції чи
варті були ось ці високі очікування ну
сам візит сюди найвищих посадовців
Європейського Союзу до Києва Він якраз і
говорить про те є інтерес їхнього боку і
вони так само розуміють тому що це війна
проти Європи яка відбувається на
українському полі бою але тому саме це в
європейських інтересах Ну і на
перспективу коли ми говоримо про те що
Українські збройні сили це вже де-факто
армія Європи Коли ми говоримо про
майбутні галузі ключові сфери Україна з
найбагатшим потенціалом критичних
мінералів коли ми говоримо про космос
військово-промисловий комплекс
ракетобудування
it тобто Україна - це яка тіста стартап
Nation Тому очевидно ми посилимо
Європейський союз із точки зору о а-а
безпеки здатності до оборони і так далі
протидії авторитаризму Мені здається що
ключове що мало би бути зараз це
прийняте рішення якого ще досі на жаль
на заході немає допомогти Україні
перемогти і не боятися поразки
військової Російської Федерації
давати нам зброї не стільки отак
дозовано чи ми будемо з вами стільки
скільки Вам треба ні
будьте з нами так щоб ми швидше
перемогли і перемогли в цьому році ви не
побачили такого бажання у європейських
партнерів які ось вчора вже були у Києві
напередодні якісь сьогодні тут є ви
бачите цей сигнал що вони готові до
перемоги саме йти а не просто щоб ми
вижили я бачу зараз в очах деяких Еліт
на заході страх страх перед тим що
поразка Росії означає хаос хтось боїться
що це якось вплине на Китай Хоча я бачу
Навпаки це буде послаблення Китаю тому
мені хочеться щоб на заході
було прийняте рішення тому що Минулого
року на саміті сімки не було прийнято
рішення по модерним Танкам для України і
тому ми втягнулися величезний pin-конг
хто коли чи білий дім дає благословення
А ні як ми маємо дати благословення
Німеччина суверена держава а шольц не
може дати без коаліції ви розумієте всі
готуються до
першої річниці повномасштабної сторони
чи геноциду я пам'ятаю як в парламенті в
2018-му ми робили великі заходи Дональд
туз виступав українською мовою це був
захід до 19-му році до п'ятиріччя
спочатку вторгнення тому мені дуже
прикро що
9-й рік війни рік геноциду і ми говоримо
зараз не про те що Україна має все
необхідне для контрнасту для
відвойовування території ми говоримо в
тому що в Україні теж мобілізація
продовжується уже майже кожна родина має
або заги або пораненого або хто отримав
повістку розуміти тому ми маємо говорити
про те що за рік ми говоримо про санкції
проти розсаду які давно мали бути
впровадженні за рік ми говоримо що Росія
збирається наступати а не ми йдемо в
Контрнаступ Чому Тому що на заході досі
нам не треба допомагати на тому рівні
щоб стабілізувати лінію фронту і думати
як сідати за перемовини Ми хочемо щоб на
всіх форматах Rammstein G7 ЄС і так далі
говорили про українську перемогу в цьому
році Оце і є ключовий меседж для світу
тому що це в інтересах не тільки
демократії Це в інтересах мільйонів
людей які не знатимуть голоду це
мільйони західних громадян які не
знатимуть інфляції які не знатимуть
гібридних атак на демократію і підриву
зокрема
комунікацій які йдуть через Балтійське
море і так далі тому давайте зупиняти
авторитаризм в цьому році і не чекати як
кожен день ми втрачаємо найкращих
українців дійсно сподіваємося що цей
2023 рік уже стане не тільки
євроінтеграційним роком має роком
української Перемоги і на цьому поки
будемо завершувати Дякуємо нашим
глядачам що дивилися назви буде стежити
за
євроінтеграційним прогресом України за
всіма новинами А ви Стежте за ними на
нашому сайті до нових зустрічей